Is one of the biggest and more
important knowledge
graphs around
and has been for
the last decade or so,
if my memory serves me right.
It has been
a knowledge graph,
before actually
knowledge graphs
were were to hike
or before even
they were to think.
So they started,
scraping knowledge
from, from Wikipedia.
And to do that they used some
structure in Wikipedia and by
doing that they
extracted a big
amount of knowledge and they
have been building on that and
creating a whole
ecosystem around it.
And this is actually what
Sebastian is here to
talk about today,
the latest addition to this
ecosystem and how
they're using it and,
I guess, how they you
can also use it.
So that's that's it,
from, from my part.
And for the rest, Sebastian,
the floor is yours,
and take it away.
Thank you for
the introduction,
George. So today,
I'm talking about
the d DBPedia
data bus, in particular,
a platform to evolve knowledge
and AI from version
web files.
This is
a particular particular
aspect which goes
into data and
knowledge engineering.
So it it is it is
about the engineering
methodology. A part of it is
about
the engineering methodology
behind it.
So you would get some some
knowledge engineering details
and processes here,
and then about the platform
which provides
the tool support
for this methodology.
So for for all of
you who do not
know DBPedia so well,
I've prepared a short
introduction.
So starting from the left,
you can see that two thousand
and seven was this
first Wikipedia
extraction thirteen years ago
with the four partners,
and there was a functioning
sparkle endpoint,
which is stably
available publicly
till today, and
also linked data
deployment. Then soon
after, basically,
in the same year,
there was this formation of
the linked data cloud
around DBPedia.
Trend continues, and,
so so then there was a major
boost in knowledge graph and
linking research.
We opened the editing
of the DVPD
ontology in two thousand ten,
which was labeled
a new type of psych.
Two thousand eleven,
there was major
industry so IBM
Watson was built,
for example,
using DVPD. Yahoo used
the the software.
BBC included the identifier.
Park was given to Unicode.
Then, two thousand twelve and
two thousand sixteen,
we extended this extraction
framework to cover all hundred
to hundred forty
Wikipedia's, comments,
and also wiki data.
And at this time,
fourteen point four billion
facts were extracted.
In two thousand fourteen,
we founded the DBPedia
Association,
which I'm the CEO of.
Two thousand sixteen,
we had we were try starting to
tackle data quality
on a larger scale.
That's why we
developed the Shackle
web standard,
which allows test
driven knowledge
graph development.
Two thousand eighteen, this,
the linked data cloud
has grown a lot.
And, starting two
thousand nineteen,
we really built DBPedia into
an innovation platform.
So it's not not really about
the dataset anymore,
but about
the connect connecting
of the data, linked
data technology,
and the ecosystem.
Now in the future,
we we kind of like
raise the the
productivity. I'll
talk about this.
So there are
twenty two billion
facts per month.
This is one thing,
so it's monthly releases.
And we have this
huge link data
derived open knowledge graph,
so we kind of, like,
increase the speed
of integration
very much and are
able to produce
this huge knowledge graph.
And also,
we started to do
FAIR link data.
So FAIR, most of
you might know it,
but it means findable,
accessible,
interoperable, and reusable.
And I'll talk about these
developments in twenty twenty
on the next slides.
So what does FAIR
linked data mean?
FAIR originally comes
from a scientific
consortium. So
there are guiding
principles for scientific data
management and stewardship.
Personally, I always wondered
these these guidelines,
they are very vague,
high level,
idealistic, also altruistic,
and not at all industrial.
So what we're doing with FAIR
linked data now is
that we provide
a practical
practical implementation
of FAIR. So there's lowered
effort because you can reuse
the implementation.
We have measurable
automated FAIR tests,
so you can be sure that your
data is FAIR, and the whole
thing is industry driven.
Now this, there
are many things
in this FAIR
guiding principles
that are industrially
relevant.
For example, findable,
there is also
a marketing aspect,
but also internal
data management
aspect that you want to find
data in in your
enterprise. Yeah.
Because it's very distributed
across your enterprise.
Interoperability
is, of course,
a great issue and reusability
is is a great cost saver.
Accessibility, goes along with
privacy concerns
and who's allowed
to see data. So this
has a different
flavor than the the original
FAIR guiding principles.
I would like to introduce you
the DVPDIA Association members
up to now. So we are very fast
growing knowledge engineering
and linked data lobby.
Part of it is to to
give the visibility
that the EPR has
back to the people
who contributed
and build it and
really drive this knowledge
graph adoption.
Let's I I would like to answer
the question
whether DBPedia is
academic and is
industrial is often,
quite a misconception.
So it's it's neither
and it's both.
Because we focus on knowledge
engineering, and
engineering is
always taking
scientific methods
to produce industrial output.
So more on the left side,
we put the academic
and nonprofit
and public members,
and then on the right side,
we put the industrial
members.
Yeah. So you can,
kind of, like,
see this this,
knowledge engineering
methodology here
or process here.
I'll talk about some,
economical concepts
just to give
a background
motivation why why
we are doing this.
Some years ago,
we had an aligned project that
was supposed to align software
and data engineering.
We also published a book,
Engineering Agile
Big Data Systems.
And if you do
a system analysis
of your data
intensive workflow,
you have these
three properties
which are agility,
productivity,
and quality.
And here I've
plotted basically
the release cycle of DVPDR in
two thousand sixteen and two
thousand twenty.
So two thousand sixteen,
we had kind of like
this entire pattern.
It is called data
quality creep.
So we were always focusing on
data quality and
totally ignoring
agility and productivity,
which means if
you if you follow
if you go into this
entire pattern
of data quality creep,
your releases will
be delayed a lot.
And this means you
you use agility
and you use, net
output. Yeah.
So productivity.
This is an automatic
triangle here.
We lost a bit of
quality because,
of course, we we reengineered
the whole pipeline.
And during this basically,
during this
refactoring process,
I think there are
minor new bugs.
Yeah. So we lost
a bit of quality,
but we kind of like increased
agility and
productivity a lot.
So the last release cycle was
seventeen months, and
now it's monthly,
and you can really
add fix the pipeline
better. Another
economic concept
is the law of
diminishing returns.
So if you have
an economic background,
you already know
what this means.
This measures
the productivity per unit.
So if you add
more workers to,
so it's the production factor
is labor here. If you
add more workers,
then you, at some point,
you're you're getting
more productive.
But then if you add
more workers to it,
you kind of, like,
have diminishing returns.
That means each worker is not
so effective anymore.
And then if you will
continue this,
let's say you want
more and more
data quality and you add more
and more people checking this
data quality,
you will even get
into negative returns.
That the main reason here is
that data quality is
Pareto efficient.
So there's a twenty
eighty rule applies.
And if you increase
in quantity,
you lower quality as well.
And also the increase
in quality
makes it harder to
find errors here.
So as a take home message,
if you ever print the slides,
you can cut this out
with the scissors.
If you want, you you should
always try to
tackle data quality
issues with innovation,
not with more community
or workforce.
Yeah. So because
of if you double
the size of your data curation
community or you
have more edits
or more activity,
it doesn't mean that you are
more productive in any sense.
So this is basically the take
home message and we have we
focus here on innovation.
Now I'll come to the core.
I'll introduce some data bus
concepts and, let me
see what's that.
No. Data bus concepts
and use cases.
It's in the mix,
so there will be high
level concepts,
and also use cases
and practical demos,
which show these.
So what's the data bus?
Data bus is a digital
factory platform.
The basic process
on the DataBus
is you find data,
you consume data,
you process data, then
you republish it.
This is a very minimal,
minimal building block.
There's this online platform,
data bus dot d b p dot org,
and it's literally built like
a like a data bus
in in your laptop,
for example. So in computer
architecture, bus
is a communication
system that transfers
data between
components inside
a computer or
between computers.
And here, of course,
we're talking in
the in the server.
It was inspired by
the Maven repository,
Steam, GitHub,
and also the APT
package manager on Linux.
So these are all software
deployment systems,
and we focus you
on on data data
consume and deployment.
What you do with this basic
building block is that you can
build networks,
and not a pipe not
a static pipeline.
So as soon as you,
build pipelines
and really hard
integrate, let me see.
Another question.
As soon as you build
hard pipelines,
you lose a lot of flexibility
and agility,
and you cannot test
the individual
data output. So what you see
here is that the metadata,
on the top the top
blue line is
the data bars. You
query the metadata
for the files, and then you
download the data from from
somewhere else.
So it gives you kind of like
the location of
the files on the web,
and then you can load it into
your data cleaning service,
into a service, into
some sort of model.
And you produce output data,
and this output data,
you can upload the metadata on
the data bus again.
So it's
basically orchestration
of input and output
between software.
So how can you
imagine a digital
black factory platform?
On the right, you
see a warehouse
with a lot of boxes.
You kind of, like,
need to know what's
in the boxes,
where they are going,
which box you need.
So the boxes here are files.
So it's the registry of files
on the web, which means that,
any files reachable via HTTP,
can be described
with this metadata.
Doesn't matter
with the whether
it's RDF, XML, JSON, PDF.
It's the central storage,
and the central metadata index
is available via
Sparkler API.
So there's a knowledge
graph as well.
Right now on
the public platform,
there are a hundred thirty
thousand files
and two point six
terabyte, and you can download
all of it. So there's
no restriction.
It's all open.
It's open data.
Maybe you don't
want all of it,
then you need to select it and
drill down with
the SPARQL API,
and it's also a FAIR
implementation.
So if you publish files
on the data bus,
we guarantee that you,
follow the FAIR principles.
So what is the core of it?
There's very strict metadata.
So this part is very
well, well checked.
So provenance,
we allow users,
organizations, and agents to
publish data.
And, of course, you
have, datasets,
source datasets.
When your dataset is derived,
you can link to
the source datasets.
Yeah. So this provenance,
machine readable
licenses is required.
Everything is signed
with a private
key and the x five zero nine
certificate. And we have,
dataset identity
and versioning,
which is a bit
different from DCAD.
So there's a gap in
the DCAD standard.
Here, you the dataset
is abstract.
And then each version you have
versions per dataset. Yeah.
So I'll show that in
the next example.
Those structure,
like the links,
are user group
artifact version.
If you know Maven,
you already,
you're familiar with this.
And I'll show you one popular
dataset of DBpedia.
So this is just
a very tiny dataset.
So these are geo coordinators
extracted with mappings.
That means from
the English Wikipedia,
you have a lot of
from, you know,
from all Wiki from from all
major Wikipedias,
it extracts
the geo coordinates
and put them into the file.
You can see if you
go on the versions
that so this is
the abstract data set.
Yeah. And then each month,
we produce a new version based
on the Wikipedia dump of this
particular dataset.
You have a a schema,
basically,
for the files.
This is important.
So you can drill down
on the individual
datasets. So now you just want
to select the English files.
And, if you want to
subscribe to it,
there is a query generation
functionality. So
each month now,
if you execute this query,
you will get this
this particular
new dataset,
just the English
version of it.
Yeah. If you click
on a version here,
there's more there's more much
more documentation
available and
also links to the codes,
and you can report
errors and discuss.
So there's interactivity
features.
There's also
the link to download
the metadata.
So this means you can automate
these downloads totally.
The next thing is so if this
gets more complicated
because we are,
the the core collection,
which I will show,
it has several hundred
files per month.
So here, users data bus users
can create their
own data catalogs,
which we call collections.
So these collections
are stable
they have stable identifiers,
so you can put them
in a scientific
paper, for example,
and they are
dynamically updated
or they can be static. Yeah.
So I'm going to
show you the latest
core release here,
which is basically what we'll
then load into
the main sparkle
endpoint, which you all know.
So here's a simple
batch script
to fetch the data.
I hope loads loads now.
Yeah. But anyhow,
the the collection is
backed by a query,
which is can get
quite long. Yeah.
So the sparkle
endpoint endpoint
is quite good to handle this.
And let's see. Yeah.
So here you can
see all the the
datasets. Basically,
each month or each day,
you can check
whether there are
updates to this collection and
then kind of, like,
replicate the DBPedia sparkle
endpoint on your
local machine.
And you cannot create your own
collections via the the if you
are registered.
So what can you do
with the collections?
There is this thing
which we call,
it's like rapid application
deployment because we need to
maintain the DBPEDI
infrastructure,
the core infrastructure.
So as I showed before,
these collections
can be loaded
programmatically. And if you
pair this with with Docker,
you get a low code application
deployment. So we have this
Docker image,
which is a virtual
sparkle endpoint quick start.
And, here, it is
a three liner.
You just feed it
the collection DPPR,
and then you need
to restart it
and it checks the updates for
the collections.
Now let's talk
about so this was
the download and action part.
Now I'm going to
talk about this
data engineering in action.
So, this part,
I I do not have
detailed slides here,
but kind of like,
if you ask what is
an application and,
of course, I mean,
data intensive
applications here.
So AI, search,
many things that
are fed fed by
a lot of data,
chatbot maybe or question
answering systems,
NLP as well.
So you have an application,
that you are developing,
and this application
here always
needs software and data.
So these are
the two components
that you that you
actually need
to have a working
application.
Now if you think
about the software
engineering part, there,
you have very good
frameworks for it.
You have Maven, you have NPM,
you have the DBN
package manager,
you have, Scala build
tools, the SPT,
for example. And there you can
really pinpoint,
the exact
software dependencies
that you need.
They're recursively
resolved and you know kind of
like for each
software artifact
you include, you know exactly
which version it is,
whether there are
compatibility issues,
whether things changed.
You have a build
tool that runs
integration tests normally.
So there are many,
many tools there.
But when you when you
think about data,
so if you present
your application
to somebody and I
would ask you,
can you give me
a list of datasets
included and where
you got them and,
like, a record on what's what
are the dependencies
and everything,
then normally, this is done
without any tools. Yeah.
So and here I see
the great, great gap.
So I prepared
some homework for
you also.
If you compare your software
engineering
processes and tools
with your data engineering
processes and tools,
so how you track
data and develop
data and everything,
do you notice a difference?
And you can think about it,
and you will see that there's
a or I assume that
you will find
a great gap. Yeah.
Because from my experience,
I was not so happy
the last ten
years working with data and
the tools provided
to work with data.
Now the main thing also may
the main incentive
to for us to
develop the data
bus is that we
want to do knowledge
graph engineering.
This means, in this case,
it's a simple example.
For us, it's
a simple example.
So it it mainly
shows the dVPDR
release process.
And we have this
fully automated,
it's in the Marvin port,
so there's fifty five gigabyte
per release,
around twenty
twenty one billion
triples per month and five
thousand triples per second.
There's also a dashboard that
tracks the process.
And on the bottom,
you can see the the the,
debugging well,
release and
debugging workflow.
So the the on the left top,
you see that we,
we take the time
based Wikipedia
dump each month,
and then there's
a time schedule
extraction. This
is uploaded on
the data bus.
And then there is
the state data
cleansing step,
which is another component.
And in the end,
there are this
downloads it and
republishes it as
quality control
DBPR release groups.
What we do then is,
there is this large
scale validation.
So we run yet other tests on
the final thing,
and this produces reports.
And here, this is the kind of
like the point
of truth is this
community reviewing. Yeah.
Because we just
produce the data,
but then it gets
downloaded six
hundred thousand
times per year,
and the errors are only shown
in the final
applications. Yeah.
So if you load it
in the sparkle
endpoint, if people
parse it, whatever.
Yeah. So and then
the the problem
here is always to backtrack,
the errors and the issues to
the specific component.
And this is something which is
possible in the data
bus because
we reach this
unity between data
package and also piece of code
and software to
which will which
is responsible for
this particular
data part.
And you can break
down the the tests
these data tests.
You can put them
into the software
integration tests.
So here, we have
kind of, like,
achieved this
alignment between
software and data engineering
and the backtracking of the of
the data issues,
in the opposite
direction of the data.
Now here, I'm go just going to
show this real short.
So here's a more complex,
knowledge graph
engineering workflow.
It is more complex
because it's
iterative. Because here,
it's not so straightforward.
So it's not like
it's not pipeline
like a pipeline.
So the release
workflow is more
like a pipeline and then you
backtrack for the errors.
Here,
the individual components
use datasets of
other, components,
but then also
improve them, and,
you have to reload
the other components.
So it's like
an iterative approach.
So the the borders between
consumption and publishing are
are kind of, like,
not so not so linear.
Yeah. It's more network like,
and this is only internally.
What we are what we're doing
with this is, we're deriving
huge knowledge graph
from linked data.
So here you can see an entity
size comparison
of the knowledge
graphs we are building.
So, the DBPedia
you you know and
you are used to is
on the left side.
Yeah. This is the English
tiny diamond.
Diamond because
it's compressed
data from several sources.
We recently built
a Dutch national
knowledge graph
from Dutch linked
data sources.
Then you have,
as a comparison,
you have items in Wikidata.
And right next to it,
there's this DBPedia
small diamond,
which compresses all language
versions of Wikipedia plus
Wikidata in in one, yeah,
like a diamond
knowledge graph.
We'll build more national
knowledge graphs in
the coming years,
like the German one
or maybe the US one.
If you're interested,
please mail me.
And, on the then
the there comes
the largest diamond,
which is kind of
like all datasets
that we integrated up to now,
compressed into
one huge knowledge
graph that you can download.
So here, we increased
the speed a lot.
So we we need to right now,
we need around four hours per
linked data cloud per linked
data bubble, and we are going
to crowdsource
this so everybody
can integrate their
data into the PDF.
Then we have these
two commercial
graphs, the Google Knowledge
Graph for comparison.
So this is log scale
and the DeepPort
knowledge graph.
And then we have, of course,
the linked open data cloud,
which is the largest knowledge
graph on Earth, I think,
compared to anything else.
There's there's more data
available there,
but not findable.
That is a problem. Yeah.
So we need to book up
the infrastructure
that can really find,
the particular data that you
need from the LOB
cloud in life
and also manage
the changing of
the data.
So now I I want to
show you a data
bus application.
So previously,
we focused on the consumer,
the download, and
also developing
methodology with
the data bus.
But you can also
build applications
which are powered directly by
the data bus. And I would say
this is a unique selling point
because this is not possible
with other data repositories.
So other data repositories,
you can kind of, like,
keep the or organize
the files a bit,
but it's very hard
to build real
applications on the repository
itself as a platform.
So this is DBP we
call it DBPedia
archival. So it's
an ontology archive.
I will show it real quick.
So what we do is we
crawl eight hundred.
So at the moment,
we discovered and
crawled eight
hundred ninety ontologies,
and then we do a star rating.
So here you can have a list of
ontologies and filter them.
Maybe some audience
want to see
their ontology.
Maybe it's we don't have time
to wait till somebody
suggest one.
But, yeah, you can try it out
later how this, the star
rating is done.
So so what it does
is, basically,
this this archival
tool discovers
and tracks all ontologies and
every eight hours,
it downloads a version
of the ontology
onto the data bus, bus,
which is persistently saved.
So this means you can now use
the data bus to download and,
the ontologies and
the individual
versions. So if you
click on let's wait.
Let's go for the latest time
stamp to see which ontologies
have been edited recently.
So here, this one,
you can see that
here every time
a change is detected,
the ontology is downloaded and
persisted, and
then we check for
parsability here.
For example, if you
only have one star,
then most likely
the license is missing.
Yeah. And then
a consistency check.
So these are
the the four stars.
So these are these
are basically
stars which are needed.
So, you know, your ontology is
is fair and available.
It doesn't say anything about
the quality, just that you can
find and access
the ontology and
that it has
a license attached.
So there are, in
the back end,
you have also
programmatic access
ontology versions.
And this is kind of
like an application
build on the on
the data bus itself.
Where two things where
I have no time,
which I just want to
mention shortly.
So there's also
a data bus client,
which is quite
practically because
it converts format
and compression
on download. So it's a bit
different than
content negotiation.
Content negotiation
does the conversion
server side. And here,
you can the the client
kind of,
like, simplifies g zed g zed g
zed to b zed to conversion or
things like that.
So it's quite practical to
homogenize the collections.
And there's also
data bus mods,
which automate the enrichment
of the metadata.
So this is like so users don't
have to give
something like a MIME
type because this can be
automatically detected
or file size or,
what many other things,
void generation,
is done automatically.
About the data bus,
the usage is free
if you register,
and we are preparing on-site
deploy on-site deployments for
the next year beginning of two
thousand twenty one,
so you can have a more closed
architecture. Yeah.
Thank you for your attention.
Are there any questions?
Oliver is asking
if there's a user
review process.
And, for example,
what happens if
you detect a bug
in the Wikipedia data?
Okay. So this is about the,
the data quality.
Yes? I think so.
Yep. So, how does it work?
So, normally, you would submit
an issue in the in the data in
the in the GitHub. Yeah?
So this issue is kind of like
not semantic yet,
or actually where
the users kind
of like, they know already how
the data bus works and how to
pinpoint the error.
But, so let's say you you have
you are not familiar
with anything.
You say, okay. I
found this is wrong,
and then you post the issue.
And what you do
what we do then
is we tag it with
the particular
artifact on the data bus.
So we say, in this version,
we confirm it in this version
of this particular artifact.
The error occurs.
From there, we device tests.
So there's a mini
dump where we
can implement software tests,
And these are in
the dev branch.
So on the dev branch,
the tests always fail.
And then as soon as
one of the tests
is fixed, it moves to
the master branch,
and then it's available next
month so it gets better.
So this is
the overall process.
Okay. There's one that I know
you're going to love because
it's one of your
favorite topics.
So, someone's asking,
like, okay.
You know, this is such a great
achievement, but,
how do you actually
manage it?
Do you have less funding,
or is it because the core team
is so dedicated?
No. No.
It is really,
so we have a so
we I have to say
we have a lot of
we have we have
a very large community,
I have to say.
So whenever so it
it is it is still,
or it comes definitely
from a community
based models models.
So, for example, he,
manages the TB,
the library now,
and gave us three servers.
There's some hosting Manheim,
open link host
domain endpoint.
So everybody is kind of like
contributing a bit.
And we are moving and and you
have to see that on the board
of DBpedia,
there are six of the top ten
knowledge engineers according
to AI Miner. So we
all won a prize,
basically, that
we are the most
influential scholars
in knowledge
engineering, and also our our
members are,
very much experts
in the field.
So you have to
there's definitely
technology leadership,
and this innovation
helps to to
keep this running.
And, we focus
the last three or
four years to really make it
because before that,
two people were
doing the release,
and they needed twelve months
or seventeen months
in some cases.
And this was very expensive,
and now we automated it.
So it just basically
can be done
by a very skilled bachelor or
master student. Yeah.
And this is kind
of like a high
cost saver because per se,
the association is unfunded.
So each of the members
has a very
huge budget. Yeah.
Like the libraries,
the companies,
the researchers, and
in this funding,
there's maybe always a work
package included,
or for businesses.
They, of course,
they want to,
show their tools
with with the PDF.
So there's some interest with
the researchers.
There's always a work package
maybe that is
particular to the PDF.
Okay. Thanks. There's actually
more questions,
but since we have
to to wrap up,
I'll just do a quick one and
give you a quick reply.
Amir is asking how
does the star rating,
ontologies work?
Is it based on,
FAIR principles?
No. It cannot be based on FAIR
the original FAIR principles
because they are too vague.
So they are kind
of like saying
that you should have this and
should have this,
but they're not
specifying it too much.
But for ontologies,
we're talking about
all ontologies,
which is a very small and
specialized area.
And there, you
can have clearly
measurable star ratings.
For the details,
you have to go to archival.
Tvpr dot org. We spent almost
two weeks describing
these stars,
so there's a lot of
information there.
Okay. Okay. Great.
Thanks thanks once
again for, the,
for the talk, Sebastian.
Thank you very
much. Bye. Bye.